hi this is Tim Jones I'm the head of
creative at rebellion and I'm here to
talk about Sniper Elite 3 and show you a
little bit of gameplay the level we're
going to show you here is actually the
second mission in the game is the Gabba
runo ASIS in which you're performing
some undercover operations to try and
track down some Intel to lead you to
taking down the Wonder buffer the wonder
weapons the evil technology that the
Nazis are working on and try and stem
their progress in the war in North
Africa what we're looking at here is the
loadout options for the player you can
choose what you take into any level
which type of rifle you can even
customize the rifles themselves with
different scopes barrels stocks and
actions all of which have different
effects on the way bullets fire the
ballistics and the like one of the the
key points for the game is that it's all
about tactical choices about how
allowing the player to choose how they
approach any given scenario we've put a
lot of effort into revamping our engine
so that we're able to do much larger
levels which offer far more nonlinear
gameplay and nonlinear options for the
player it's got a more sophisticated
lighting solution and the level of
detail were able to deliver is is way
above what we were previously doing
so what we'll do is we'll start by
showing you a little bit of the the
stealth side of the gameplay here we can
see there is a an enemy troop just up
ahead of us here and we'll use our
ability to take him down silently before
he spots us and before it's fixed that
generator just there which is going to
help this going to help us use to mask
the sound of our rifle fire with these
my binoculars now before you go into any
given scenario it's a good idea to stop
and take a good look at the situation
with your binoculars and used them to
tag your targets so you can see here as
you tagged your targets it'll show you
details about them what weapons they're
holding their current like alertness
state how far they are away and also you
can see how they render through the
environment which means that it's very
easy to keep track of them even when
they're out of sight
once we've just tagged all the people we
can see then we can get into some
sniping first target should be the one
on the sniper tower up there because if
we shoot him no one else is going to see
him you die and also if we can time it
to coincide with one of the back firings
of the generator there then it'll be
completely unheard by anyone else no one
heard that shot go off and they will
sort and die so everything's still
silent
for us to continue how we choose to
approach a situation you're seeing here
our new improved revamped x-ray killcam
popular feature in the last game this
time around we've souped it up with
muscle layers circulatory systems far
more dynamically breaking bone fractures
and even 3d blood particles
we'll note as we hold our breath and
take aim the marker appears below the
center of the rescue and that's actually
indicating where the bullet is going to
drop under gravity which is a big part
of the the ballistics system in the game
which is in a very accurately modeled
using real-life physics on harder
difficulty levels you even have to take
care of things like wind effects in
combination with your own heartbeat
breath control and the distance fall
under gravity our key target right here
is the one marked with a star we've got
to take him out and collect some Intel
from his body so we'll try and whittle
down the opponents around here so we've
just got the one guy left
okay now we came taking a couple of
shots that weren't masked by sound the
enemies pinpointed our position if we
look back to where we were you can see a
ghost image of ourselves and that's
indicating where the enemy think we
think we are or the last place they saw
us and we can use that to our advantage
by flanking the AI we could even trap
like I put in a booby trap of that
position which would take them out as it
is we'll just shoot them from behind
if you move far enough away from your
last known position then you'll have a
successful relocation and the AI will
have lost your position entirely at
which point you can continue with being
stealthy
I'll talk it up there he's you can see
by the red ring above his head he's
still really concerned that all his
buddies are dead but he's not seen us
for a long enough that he's now going
back to his passive state we're able to
take him down
and having done so you can now search
his body for the Intel we're after
it's it's worth noting that that
encounter there could play out any
number of different ways it's entirely
up to the player how they approach it
whether they go guns blazing will they
creep around sort of killing everyone
with a knife to the back whether they
throwing in grenades or using booby
traps it's entirely up to the player
often you'll find because the AI so
intelligence you can start with one plan
but quickly enough to adapt to another
as we move into the next area we should
get the opportunity to show how we use
some of the other toys in our inventory
we've got different booby traps we've
got tripmines landmines bouncing Betties
we can set small fires to attract AI
attention
I'll throw rocks to distract them all of
which is good if you're trying to keep
out of the line of fire so here just
throw a rock and you should see how the
AI will hear it go and investigate in
that direction while we sneak around
behind them
I think we would just spot it nope I
think we got away with it it's a shot to
the head with the silenced well rod
pistol and bodies well out of the sight
of the others so we should be good to
continue on our way and again you'll see
that with every kill we make there are
you gain experience points tracks
exactly how you did it whether the
character was isolated
whether you tagged them previously what
weapon you use to take them down and
you're rewarded with XP points for
everything you do in the game which all
contributes to leveling up getting
promotions and unlocking further
equipment and customization options for
your rifles that system works in both
multiplayer and single-player and
carries between the two allowing the
player to approach things as they want
so just take the opportunity to tag the
enemies around here making sure we can
keep track of them and might be a good
idea to try placing some some mines to
cover our back at this point so for
place a landmine just here and then head
back around to the sniper nest we've
just ahead back
silently kill the guard on duty here
hope there was no one bellows I think we
got away with it
and you'll know there's a generator just
here which we can actually sabotage
ourselves to create a sound masking
event which we can use to mask our rifle
shots in this next section
another of our targets ahead we do a
quick check of the map then we can see
how there are three targets marked with
a star on the map it's up to us exactly
which order we take them in exactly how
we how we go about taking down those
targets and getting the Intel they're
spread across the map which is you know
huge and nonlinear but we'll just deal
with the guy that's right in front of us
at the moment you can see also because
he's been tagged you can see his rank is
marked with the three stripes above him
he's an officer and it's always a good
idea to take our officers first because
they offer a boom to the other people in
their squad to make them more aggressive
able to see further so if you take him
out first then it gives you a better
chance against the rest okay he's down
Sam asked isolated
get this guy okay we've been heard they
still don't know exactly where we are we
take a few more shots they'll quickly
identify where we are but hopefully that
landmine replaced will recover us
[Music]
shop you'll see there we managed to
shoot through the fabric of the tent
we've got a full bundle bullet
penetration system as part of our
ballistics so thin layers of words and
fabric won't actually block your rifle
bullets so you can actually shoot
through them there's another good reason
to tag your enemies
there's a good reason to keep an eye on
what's going on behind you at all the
times the AI are pretty smart and they
will try and flank you wherever possible
so all this is playable in single-player
but every single one of the missions in
the main campaign is playable by up to
two players online core particularly as
well which further opens up a lot of
options of how you can approach the
level
yeah you can shoot people movies and
expert detail yeah it was a popular
feature in the in Sniper Elite v2 we
yeah we debated about whether to put it
into that game and it ended up being
extremely popular for one reason or
another and yeah it's making a return in
this one so pouch cooperative play is a
big part of the game and we've got a
number of different cooperative
challenge modes available the popular
overwatch mode from the first game is
returning in overwatch mode you've got
the two players taking different roles
one of whom is the sniper now there is
the operative on the ground able to mark
out targets for the sniper you really
have to work together to take out your
objectives we've also got a survival
mode where you both have to work
together to survive against increasing
numbers of enemies increasing difficulty
and vehicles and that's a lot of fun and
very challenging and if you're feeling
really tough you can also go ahead and
try that in single-player as well in
addition to that we've got adversarial
multiplayer available from day one for
up to 12 players online on all formats
and we've got deathmatch Team Deathmatch
really cool mo called
distance King in which you get rewarded
for long range shots and no cross where
both teams are separated and can't go
into each other's area which is pretty
challenging game as well
as in a big change one of the things we
really wanted to improve upon from
Sniper Elite v2 was to make sure the
game was far more nonlinear really open
to the player how they approached each
level each objective so you can take any
route you want you're not being ferried
down a corridor in a kind of a pop up
shooter kind of way it's really open and
really open to the player about how they
approach things as part of the reason we
went for North Africa as a location with
this kind of organic environments with
different encampments in it is a bit of
a sniper's paradise and ideal for the
kind of stealth gameplay and tactical
choice we wanted to offer to the player
we've tried to maintain a balance to
make sure that it really is open to the
player how they approach any scenario
but we're definitely encouraging stealth
much more this time around it's way a
lot of players really wanted to be able
to behave but in the previous game you
might get the situation where you step
Romney or make a sound and get hurt and
then suddenly it feels like the entire
German army knows exactly where you are
and you're under a lot of threat at that
point this time around we put a lot of
effort into the feedback to the player
letting you know what the AI thinking
making the AI a lot more sophisticated
in how they behave so that you can
actually really manipulate the situation
and if things do go slightly not
according to plan you can recover it you
can get out you can relocate wait till
things calm down again and then carry on
your way but if players want to be all
out like really aggressively shooting
their way through they can try but it'll
be tough the AI are tough we've got a
number of different difficulty modes as
well to accommodate different styles of
play we're on the default difficulty
mode here
which is challenging in itself certainly
but on harder difficulty modes there'll
be more effects on the bullet the
ballistics involved that you have to
take account of things like wind which
will be blowing the bullet left and
right there'll be fewer of the online
on-screen visual indicators to show you
what the AI are thinking and doing the
AI will react much faster as well in the
heart of difficulty modes and we've also
got customization customization
available to the difficulty modes as
well so the players can really like pick
what aspects they want whether they want
really hard AI but with a full set of
visual feedback about what's going on or
easy AI but no visual feedback it's all
open to the player about how they
approach things so this is this is Tim
Jones I've been showing you a bit of
Sniper Elite 3 the game is coming out on
the 1st of July in the US and 27th of
June in Europe on PlayStation 4 Xbox one
Xbox 360 Playstation 3 and PC
you
[Music]